if you didn't notice the nod to a
martial arts film legend in the third
season of the umbrella academy we don't
blame you it's a really deep cut keep
watching for this nod to movie history
that could have been besides a killer
soundtrack and time travel plot lines
that bend fans minds one thing that the
umbrella academy has always done right
is its impressive fight scenes the third
season is no exception as characters in
this weird and wonderful series dirty up
their knuckles tentacles or edges always
managing to look good while doing so yet
there's one character who has largely
avoided throwing hands which is
impressive given that he's fully capable
of walking on them it's a har greaves
trainer guardian and dapper ape pogo
aiden gallagher's five can attest to
pogo's history of scratching you were a
diaper-wearing chimp in dire need of a
manicure i don't know if you remember
but i have a scar to prove it but the
ape has largely stayed out of the team's
various battles opting instead to our
viewers simply with his presence besides
looking mean as hell as a member of the
mothers of agony with the top knot and
eyebrow piercings the flashback to his
departure from the academy also sees him
in pretty cool threads in a decked out
dojo that sees ben take on jaime our
favorite tape at the academy is seen
looking stoic pogo's outfit quite
frankly makes him look 10 times cooler
than he already is it's an ensemble that
also harkens back to one of the most
iconic moments in the career of martial
arts hero bruce lee and was refitted for
another popular movie before pogo tried
it on for size in his own stylish way
few martial arts movie stars have ever
looked as good or thrown fists as fast
as a legendary bruce lee lee was largely
responsible for bringing hong kong
action to western cinema he tragically
died in 1973 but left behind an
incredible legacy with films like the
big boss his magnum opus enter the
dragon and the posthumous release game
of death the latter released in 1978
debuted what is perhaps lee's most
iconic outfit a yellow tracksuit with
black stripes on the sides that striking
look has worked its way into movie
history in more ways than one in 2003
the same ghetto was given a loving
homage in director quentin tarantino's
kill bill volume 1 when uma thurman wore
a variation of it to play the sword
swinging bride according to a medium
post lee's daughter shannon lee said her
father saw this tracksuit as a statement
he hoped would symbolize his philosophy
for martial arts and life in general she
explained
my father chose a yellow and black
tracksuit that he wore in game of death
to represent his idea of the style of
nostyl he wanted to wear something that
didn't signal that he was affiliated
with any particular style he was instead
representing himself and his own style
yes lee's eye-catching outfit was black
on yellow while pogo's is reversed but
that's no mistake if anything it's an
even deeper cut in bruce lee history
while that bright yellow tracksuit is
synonymous with lee it turns out we
could have seen him in an entirely
different one that was more in line with
what pogo wears according to game of
death producer andre morgan who spoke to
the south china morning post in 2015 lee
had a steely eyed glare on two outfits
the one we know and love as well as
another with the colours reversed the
final decision was settled thanks to a
planned showdown involving lee's last
opponent in the film played by kareem
abdul-jabbar abdul-jabbar's character
was meant to kick lee's character in the
chest showing a visible footprint on his
clothes lee settled on the yellow outfit
because the evidence of the attack would
be far more noticeable on yellow than
black while it's not a dead on accurate
nod to the martial arts hero the
iconography in the umbrella academy
flashback can't help but conjure images
of lee in his classic movies while still
leaning into themes that the umbrella
academy has established this season
focuses on choices and the fallouts that
comes from them whether it's picking an
alternate group of specially gifted
children or a wardrobe choice
pogo certainly made a great one here but
we'll stop we don't want to embarrass
him that's enough check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about the umbrella academy
are coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]